hi i'm alex from tasty we recently
partnered with Oscar Mayer to create a
recipe for the ultimate hot dog wedding
to serve the ultimate hot dog lovers I
just got back from the wedding and I
can't wait to share the recipe with you
the wedding was a absolute blast I was
so excited to just be a part of their
love Ali and Colin were an amazing
couple they were so silly it was so fun
to see how clearly in love they were
everyone was loving the hot dog wedding
the theme was OnPoint the decorations
were unique there was mustard fountains
and hotdogs ornaments laser-etched buns
with all of our names for place cards
the details were incredible so first up
we have the caramelized onion and
horseradish weenie crostini this one has
a little bit of sweetness from the
Carmelites onion and that kick from the
horseradish for the tomato lovers I
think we came up with the perfect recipe
we've got a bruschetta weenie crostini
kind of refreshing and light we really
wanted to craft the recipe to match the
newlyweds love of hot dogs but we also
wanted to elevate the dish to fit
perfectly as an elegant wedding
appetizer I grew up eating hot dogs at
baseball games and barbecues and
birthday parties there's all different
types of hot dogs all different kinds of
toppings they're all customizable one of
the reasons I love cooking so much is
the joy that you can bring into people's
lives and lastly an herbed ricotta and
honey weenie crostini with a little
touch of sweetness and that creaminess
from the ricotta everyone can agree that
the wedding was one of the most
memorable weddings I've ever pinned to I
mean the ring bearer was the Oscar Mayer
weenie Rover how could you just not be
happy when you're having this silly hot
dog wedding now I want my own hot dog
wedding I loved watching people's faces
light up when they saw the weenie
crostinis and took their first bite I
just had the best time at this hotdog
wedding it was so amazing to see this
beautiful couple come together for the
love of
so we watched the wedding we cried some
tears we ate some good food and then we
danced our buns off pun very much
intended
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]